we've got a voicemail number the number
is two one nine to david p here is a
voicemail that came in from the infamous
Troy York I kind of feel bad sometimes
when people are living in a total
fantasy world and it appears that Troy
York is doing that take a listen to what
he had to say back when you're wrong
this is a center-right nation always had
been why don't you do a program on the
alternative left a transnational global
is to go from country to country try to
grow the politics in the country with
their fake polls that don't prove
nothing they list a bunch of holes I've
never been at a poll question my life
it's all fake salt bull and you know it
alright let's what it's not alright this
goes on for several minutes the trans
nationalist globalist alternative left
is apparently really the issue for Troy
York and because he has never personally
been polled of course there's no such
thing as real pulse they're all just
made up Pat it's like one of those
people who don't believe in global
warming because it snowed the other day
or it's cold where they live and they
live you know in myn estat Minnesota or
something like that do you feel bad for
people like Troy York who seem really to
be living in an alternate reality that
that does not mirror empirical realities
I think ignorant is bliss to a certain
extent so I don't feel too badly are you
jealous of people who are living in
alternate realities see that's a good
question I don't know probably not think
about it think about it get back to us
Pat that's when Pat's going to have to
think on for a little bit on the bonus
show today six hundred pounds of
methamphetamine lollipops seized in
Texas Greg Ginn forty the body-slamming
congressman-elect
has been sentenced after the body
slamming of that reporter Ben Jacobs
what has he been sentenced to we will
talk about all of those stories and more
on the bonus show get instant access by
signing up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership wants a
discount have a discount use the coupon
code
I voted 17 you can also pledge as little
as a dollar a month towards our show at
patreon
dot-com slash David Pakman show